what up reject nation greg john and coy
big miss marvel fan over here she's a
great character she's a great character
we're going to watch miss marvel episode
2 today very excited to check it out
this is a quick heads up full length
watch along where you sing up with the
timecode for a super sexy rejects over
our patreon page cover a bunch of stuff
over there as well leave a like that
would be very much appreciated and your
thoughts down below on this episode
subscribe and click that bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
miss marvel episode is up and then boys
at prepper thanks for helping us edit
down these highlights lastly i want to
genuinely thank athletic greens for
partnering up with us since the last
time we mentioned athletic greens like
i've been in the middle of moving
hopefully by the time this video's out
i've already moved and so there's been a
lot of stuff coming out so there's been
like barely any sleep to occur however
and he will attest i've been drinking
athletic greens every single day and it
has genuinely helped so we're going to
talk more about them uh after the
reaction but yeah i just wanted to say
thank you because having some brand
partnerships lately has really been
helping out with uh hiring some extra
help and some other people and i'm going
to steal a sample
hiring to pay other people
[Music]
you know what i love about airpods that
you don't have to stand that's close by
each other
i am so sorry no worries
[Music]
make a move because the videos you sent
me were just flashes of pink light and i
didn't see anything you didn't see
anything i tried to shrink and and fly
and talk to ants and then if it worked
i mean she had physical contact with the
superhero obviously people are going to
be interested it's because like
she knew that like i could be the one to
handle
oh my god and then this like beautiful
white light like cascaded over me i knew
i was sick
there's another superhero catastrophe
and she's sitting there bragging about
being saved by the budget captain marvel
thank you thank you yeah someone finally
said
which is why
i'm gonna have a party on friday you
know to
celebrate the fragility of life
nice
yeah we're so not going to that party
well i'm having a party on friday you
should come yeah no that sounds really
fun actually yeah thank you cool we
should be at that party
what
oh
poor brew now guy in the chair
so i guess super strength is not a part
of the equation
i saved you
[Laughter]
only because you almost killed me first
still counts okay maybe i do need to
work on my skills
i don't stay put i stay grind
training montage yes singular push-up
montage
[Music]
damn how do you shoot that yeah
that's this could say there's a lot of
like really subtly impressive effect
shots
oh my is perfect for this toned show
[Music]
tone show this tone of show
no m.i.a like totally fits this world
yeah this tone show
tone show
tone locks brother tone show
tough love
god even i know you're being too lucky
you really gotta fix this place the
men's section is pristine
no talking during the lecture please
sorry shake up the light you know it's
just really hard to concentrate when we
can barely see you sister
the partition and the side entrance are
there to preserve all our modesty and
dignity thank you sister kamala for
reminding us that it is important to
share your voice though perhaps except
during my lecture
[Laughter]
and another reminder nominations are
still open for the most part election oh
my god
do i look like a nine-year-old man to
you
no
no no no no no come on somebody stole my
shoes
when you versace's maybe we'll run for
the moss board and actually make some
change around here yeah your sheets got
nothing on you baby okay you're the
change the change is here and the change
is her everyone
so that is graffiti last time zoey's
having some people over tonight
bruno and akio will both be there and
i'll be home by nine but this time
you see that you come back through the
door bring hulk down yes always bring up
that
even like beyond the emotionality
connection like the casting is visually
great too like everyone looks like both
their age and their like family yeah
that looks just like her mom very true
man
is there alcohol on that no it's just
orange juice
sure
dude why would you do
the that that's not cool what's maneuver
no we can't
everyone's here including us
don't jump dudes
[Music]
oh is that new boy yeah yeah it's new
boy that's a good way to die
nope
great way to make an entrance too
look at this guy
she's subtle she's drunk
marvel body shots
i can't do time okay guys i have a call
so everyone just called me
everyone at the party q7 getting my
small sports car so cool
i love the color he seems so serious at
high school
he's a senior what she did you backed up
into the car remember
thanks bryn i almost forgot about that
it's fine i failed my first time as well
so you could just drive my car so i
figured out you'll figure it out do you
like watching
bollywood movies and stuff uh obviously
but only the greats like why's it go all
the other stuff like that i mean it
doesn't surprise you like basketball
it's only srk's best word
yeah srk your opinion says ddlj
of course
right there
i watched it a few years back it was
very pleasing
[Laughter]
great critical analysis
very pleasing i'm very put that on the
poster
here's my number
give me a text or drop me a call make
sure i can save yours as well and uh
yeah what a nice guy
it's great meeting you guys
um miguel paul
nakia
ryan
we don't talk about brewing
no i'm gonna talk about brian for sure
out of everything
is great
that is a great fade
yeah
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
how is zoe's house oh it's magical
[Laughter]
love the subjectivity
the reality
those are some great effects i love the
use of digital in the world
it's so cool
[Music]
oh my my whole life i've
either been
too white for some people or too ethnic
for others
and it's been this very i can relate
with that
[Laughter]
i kind of realized i don't really need
to prove anything to anybody like when i
put this on i feel like me like i have a
purpose
probably why i ran for the mosque board
remember you're the one who convinced me
to do it in the first place
i love you
oh um
i got you something for your driving
lesson i feel like this is her first job
like she's very good yeah yeah oh
all my dreams are coming true
hello to see hearns and dana interact
and florence today from euphoria
you're sitting down
[Laughter]
the early immersion program at caltech
you got it
cal tech
i don't know what to say
you say yes
can i think about it okay
bruno
[Laughter]
you know that part in the movie where
someone comes in to the main character
and they say
you want to be a jedi you want to answer
phones have a demanding but impossibly
chic magazine
well that's this moment that is
happening to you right now
you're the lead character i'm meryl
streep
unleash your inner hat away
but it's in california
away from kamala
oh
okay hi my name is
yeah you good ducky i can't really train
today
what
why
oh um i'll see you later okay
oh buddy just build some tech to kill
this guy man
we're just gonna become the villain
are you sure yeah de-stress after school
first thing you can do drive
bruh
now that bro so cool don't tell me you
have a massive crush on keto too
my um uh my mom just literally upset me
and that's great still has a huge crush
on king or senior yeah
concerning several kingdoms anthony
oh shoot why are
we my brother and this beyonce he's
going to freak out
okay and then i'm going to freak out
[Laughter]
a great frame
oh
brother
sister
this is comrade
he's our cousin
he's source
is
from pakistan how come you have a
british accent oh
i'm a huge fan of the great british bake
off
i love that show i just binged it so i
was just doing a bit oh man
okay we should go
i think i remember you man
some things on the internet we called
you haram.com ron i'm gonna call you
that from now on all right dude all
right
all right oh no
it wasn't a goth phase oh yeah
i just wore a lot of black that's why we
moved to america right so that our
children could be anything that they
wanted to be almost anything
anything with our strict approval not a
superhero every pakistani family has a
partition story and none of them are
good
enough this is not about the partition
okay
this is a celebration
makes sense why they fear so much for
safety all the time uniba's mother
she got separated from her parents on
the train station
nobody knows how that little toddler
sunnah
managed to get back on the tree just
before the train pulled out of the
station
sana always said that
she followed a trail of stars
where can i see a trail of stars at some
point
wowie
so like the history remains imbued in
there like an anime what the bengal it
does some really
weird things and and that
belongs to my mother aisha the one who
disappeared during politician my
great-grandmother faisha but no i've
spoken too much already no no oh oh so
this belonged to aisha and you really
have no idea what happened to her oh
dang
sorry
[Laughter]
hey
don't question my love for the captain
kid if it wasn't for slippery when wet
your father and i may never have met
oh yeah that was gross
there's that jersey culture do you know
what happened to our great grandma
aisha where did you hear that name
from nani brought shame on our entire
family please let it go
damn but that happened i don't know you
it looks so great because it's not too
um
right i don't understand the questions
[Laughter]
that you have to make it past the mini
girls and blast the ones who know it all
and will not let you forget it the
illuminati
just murks them all on the spot
she's helping me exercise our right as
citizens of this great nation to
participate in democracy it's wonderful
wouldn't
rob two young women
of that future would you uncle
i mean come on this is kamala and me
commona khan
[Laughter]
how are we today miss uh zimmer is this
about the party because it really was
not that loud you're not the zoe zimmer
the only one i know what you have got to
be kidding i'm a big fan
oh my gosh this guy's [ __ ] well i'm so
glad you liked it and you went to
avenger con oh my gosh you must been
mobbed by all your fans no no you have a
good time it was
[Laughter]
this guy's
great i i didn't really get a good look
at her i mean it all happened so fast
did she have an accent no
was she latina
i'm sorry i'm supposed to say
latinx now right debatably middle
eastern
perhaps
south asian
you're doing a bad job
this is my thing
oh your great grandmother
my father called her a snake she put a
curse on everything she touched curse
heard she had many affairs and she had a
secret family i heard she killed a man
dead happened during partition i'm sure
she wasn't that bad
that's not gonna go down
[Music]
all the avengers show up
there's one little boy
hey hey where's going
uh i think she went home with her
parents
nah
oh i thought they're gonna do okay this
works so he's got it with her
yo it's night life nightlight
all the way up here why did i do this
[Music]
it's good it's good exposition kid it's
a good question script
do you have a favorite food ice cream
pizza she's going to say please help him
is that two foods or one food one i put
ice cream on pizza does anyone say ice
cream pizza
[Laughter]
start selling that at my stand
[Music]
trail of stars
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
superhero landing
you better get him off that platform yep
he's gonna panic
wowie
when you fall down trees
yep you just hope it's enough
how could she do that
she clearly didn't try to save him
afterwards
good sound effects
you know got a little glass sound little
point
[Music]
oh wow hold right where you are
[Music]
oh
damn
get in come on
come on
i've been waiting a very long time
[Music]
i'd like you to meet my mom they are
related
wowie
you remember when you googled and the
name popped up and i went oh no because
it taught me way too much that was the
moment oh really yeah that's a big
character from like a recent arc they
did it way early i'm sorry that google
google telling me names
wait so they are related
in a way
and he's another character too he's not
just that character my main concern is
like where are the relationships
i don't care about spoilers i saw some
hand holders oh yes hey
she was sent to him and he seemed into
her he said they travel a lot it sounded
like they had something to do with you
know shenanigans
they were up to some shenanigans i
thought it was just like real estate
problems
i know that he stays up who stays title
now we wait for a post credit scene they
might be here guys
i took my headphones off last time i was
foolish you're supposed to be the marvel
guy you're supposed to know when there's
post-credits scenes i'm sorry that was
ruined for you it was just so you saw a
twist coming yeah
because i read the comics like a fool
that's your fault man stupid no post
criticism we're not real marvel why'd we
wait you're not a real mcu yeah really
you would give us a bunch of stuff in
the credits department of damage
controls were grooting avengers the dark
ones yeah yeah yeah they should cut
spiderman
that's what they're doing i'm pretty
sure that's what's happening the dark
avengers are getting formed by the girl
from seinfeld
all right guys
i don't have time for cory's jokes
anymore
let's talk about this seriously all
right well
i'm sure
john and coy have a lot of thoughts
and i have
thoughts too but before we go into those
thoughts if you want to feel like a
superhero
you should listen to a work from our
sponsor today thank you to athletic
greens for partnering up with us this
month well the schedule is wild as ours
it's tough to stay on top of proper diet
and nutrition luckily athletic green's
eg1 formula makes your daily nutrition
simple delicious inconvenient get bigger
just one scoop contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals probiotics and a whole
bunch more which supports gut health
nervous and immune systems energy focus
plus on a serious note ag-1 is lifestyle
friendly i'm actually allergic to dairy
so any shake i ever have has to be
dairy-free so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free it's a
good fit plus it's completely natural no
harmful chemicals or gmos and for my
sake it helps to improve my sleep
quality and mental clarity which is
always a boost it helps improve my gut
health i like to poop and i like saving
money and what's great about athletic
greens is your subscription only costs
about three dollars a day that's double
what i paid john and it comes with a
year supply of vitamin d and all that is
way cheaper than trying to get all these
supplements individually so head on over
to athleticgreens.com regex to start
your ag1 lifestyle today no seriously
thank you athletic greens you guys uh
that that stuff that's really has been
very you've been drinking it too lately
don i subscribed
did you myself
i'm going to try this stuff i'm saying
when it's done sold on it when we're
when we're done with our partnership
athletic greens i am no longer drinking
now i'm actually i like their stuff a
lot yeah it's a big help i i genuinely
talk about energy built it into my day
you saw me before we filmed i actually
pay attention today look at you i'm
often tired lethargic and i need more
athletic greens well maybe you don't eat
taco bell before you show up you know
what happens
when you live next to a weekend
there's tons of greens in it frisco
guys we need to focus cory gets paid by
the second
second here it's not brought to you by
taco bell john why don't you go first i
enjoyed this continuing developing
installment of the story this feels like
a very natural progression certain of
the marvel tv series feel more smooth
than others and thus far this feels like
a very smooth feed from first episode
into the second episode i really do feel
like i'm watching a movie progress in
installments in a lot of ways and i very
much appreciate that and i mean here it
kind of did what i was hoping last time
where it seems like we're diving closer
and closer into her past and her
heritage and where those powers are tied
to that obviously setting up to the
greater world stakes of what the dodc is
able to do in interfering and regulating
and containing what kamala is up to and
yeah i've been loving the growth of the
characters and the way that they're able
to balance out you know the on the
ground level stuff like with nakia
running for um
you know for for uh uh mosque board and
all that stuff and everything feels
proportionate and everything feels alive
and yeah it doesn't feel like the big
marvelly stuff is competing with the
story stuff yo john i totally agree with
you on everything i think you said
um
what really dawned on me this time have
you seen the movie turning red yeah i
enjoyed it have you seen turning red i
have not but i'll watch it along with
you on patreon when i do
that yeah
this is how many fandoms do i have to be
100 dedicated to all of them
have you been on the internet there are
a lot of qualities of this that are kind
of like turning red yeah i also think
it's a really useful way of telling uh a
unique story in a familiar way like we
said in the first episode that kind of
escalated here much like turning red yes
well also like with the family history
the lineage the pair the parental stuff
like there's a lot that feels very
similar in terms of except with the
whole like you know she doesn't turn
into a big panda here or does she does
she will see guys we saw that thing with
the nose she might become a panda in the
end a big cosmic panda this is why i
usually lead these because i have the
smart things i mean the guy top of them
my brain has an extra wrinkle like
there's no point in you stop watching
they just stopped all the corrective
takes that we need to hear what i find
very fast about the quality of this show
a lot of the times they'll
start implementing heritage cultures
other qualities and a lot of times that
feels like backdrop or secondary both of
these episodes the high school quality
the heritage the culture all those
things that usually feel secondary are
so
primary that i'll forget that oh yeah
this is a superhero show they come in so
much later in both of these episodes the
first episode thought okay all right so
we set it all up we got that crazy
ending
cool now let's go gung-ho superhero
not really like you do some of the
training which kind of felt like shazam
a little bit yeah that's some gym
gentlemen
are you referring to dc's captain marvel
oh that's ironic i like that nicely done
nicely done
because shazam was named captain marvel
but then there was legal issues where
they couldn't use the name captain
marvel but then at the end of the day
technically he's still called captain
marvel even though miss marvel and you
know captain marvel of the one she
admires is also the same name as the
shazam character of which we're
referring this guy is so aware he gets
paid by the minute shazam was the word i
was trying to say i was trying to speed
up but then greg gave crap so i was
trying to be helpful but no no since he
interrupted i had to explain the joke
that was very
this whole thing about shazam and
captain marvel i didn't know what to be
mad about no you're not he wants to be
mad it was a legal issue when they both
had two characters
i just need to know what to be outraged
about
just pick something and go and this
point someone will join her in that
computer screen
yeah i think feigned outrage would
really help us blow up that's how we get
there guys we haven't tried it in two
years marvel forcing this female
perspective on me man oh man is there a
girl one out of 37 properties is mgu now
that we've had four women as leads out
of 37 films they're clearly adjusting
for half the population roughly 52
percent there's only one white guy and
he's just a friend and he has
extraordinary smarts
frankly demoralizing and imagine the
white man
look you guys go way off topic too much
and i'm sorry for setting you up to be
off topic you've given up
get back on the tracks people here we go
i agree with you john it does it does
feel like
because this is not the most cinematic
of them all in terms of although there's
an argument to be made for that i would
say i think it's more cinematic than a
lot of them because it's so stylized and
the quality of the imagery and they and
the way they implement the effects of
being because they this show does such a
good job at thrusting you into her
perspective that's when they go all like
whack-a-doodle-do with the visuals that
i think are so beautiful to look at and
times i like when they like sneak up on
you when you don't see the visuals like
like the bad one
yeah that was one of my favorites that
was so pretty and it also feels like a
comic book because a lot of times the
comic book imagery looks scott pilgrim
it comes out of nowhere or it's really
subtly in there but this has so many
frames that are existing simultaneously
that it feels like a comic book frame
where you can add in some onomatopoeias
some descriptive dialogue some because
you can't have a text sound in a comic
book because it's a page so i love that
they have this imagery that feels like
it's right from the books i think this
is a pretty solid show so far sometimes
i do find myself a bit craving a lo
maybe because i've been conditioned
i do wonder that about myself cause i'm
so used to like we're sitting down here
we're gonna watch a superhero show so
sometimes i expect a little bit more of
that superhero umph i don't really know
if that's a problem for me or if that's
just my preconceived notions about
thinking we're last left off so we're
probably gonna go gung-ho superhero
because i'm actually enjoying it when i
when i forget about that and then i get
lost in you know like the storyline of
uh uh what was her name and that was
probably that's for the mosque isn't it
nakia i don't know you're more likely
what does it mean because i don't know
if i'm getting confused with black
panther's nokia but i thought that was
it is
pronounced because i've only ever read
it but it's spelled
n-i-k-i-a i believe yeah okay microphone
oh it's a microphone here we are this is
this yeah
that storyline i find really fascinating
and and it seems like they're really
going to tie it all together though it
is still going to be like the superhero
show because clearly all this stuff that
the mom is kind of clued in on about
mystical past and whatever and why it
seems to be a bit of this thing where
she's so
dismayed by the concept of superheroes
it seems so tied in
yeah it seems so tied into wherever her
pain stems from and getting this uh what
is the word uh the not what the p word
what was it the pair
the the when they're talking about the
past the pair oh the partition partition
partition the partition thank you john
thank you john for being the word guy i
got some words more than us
yeah yeah be the be the thought guy
what's up what's going on there at the
end without spoiling too without
spoiling too much because we we were
looking up the cast and there's a
character which we met this episode who
is many things in the comic books and i
will say without giving away too much
he's not just the person we've met he is
also another character who i really
enjoy from the comic books and i do
believe if they go with the storyline i
think they're taking this on which is a
more recent arc there's going to be a
twist on the twist we just got things
aren't as they seem even in the
like there's a double agent situation
perhaps being unfolded i'm trying not to
give anything away so people aren't like
ah spoilers for in the comics but there
is an opportunity for us to have a a
twist on the twist with a dual identity
of this other guy if they do that but
what i think the show one of the things
i'm finding the strength of is where we
had the falcon winter soldier show kind
of being a backdoor pilot for the dark
avengers or thunderbolts whichever way
they take it we had you know a darker
captain america we had you know the the
assembly that brought us a new black
widow those things this very much feels
like they're going to use the dodc to
kind of radicalize the
champions aka and i think the young
avengers so in the comics you've got two
different teams there's the new avengers
as well as the dark avengers there's
also the dark avengers as well as the
thunderbolts and those both separately
could exist but with movies and things
you don't want to confuse the audience
so i do i do think they're gonna kind of
bring these chunks of characters
together into one unit like i was saying
last episode uh champions are very
important in street level but i do think
they're going to kind of make the young
avengers and the champions into one
thing i think they're going to kind of
summarize up that world so i do think
while we're getting one team of adult
dark avengers or thunderbolts we're also
getting a radicalized more politicized
more street level team of kids that are
going to have a lot to come from because
if you look at what just happened to
wanda's kids if they get those powers
that's going to be hugely important
we've also got kate bishop who's been
when like you know organized crime she's
going to be like street level but you
know going through these things we've
met like seven of these children who've
all gone through these traumatic events
and now kamala's going through it with a
legal side so i do think we're gearing
up towards a team of younger child
avengers who have all been through
trauma but also we're gonna be having to
fight the man itself like we're gonna be
fighting the government they're gonna be
active fighting law and i think that's
where we're going to get the she-hulk
and daredevils and such that i was
alluding to last week but more as a team
i could see an entire like young
avengers movie be about like you know
their civil war and it looks like we're
going there with the dodc can kids be
heroes
the question is like who's at fault if
you're 15 or 16 and you cause damage
like think about it they're the
department of damage control you can't
sue a child or you sue the parent is the
parent if they don't know what fault is
it evil legally acceptable for someone
to be you know i mean like there's so
many ramifications of a child putting on
a mask does a child have rights at a
point like does a child have the ability
to use those powers and i do think long
term i don't think it's going to lead
directly into but i do think that's
going to lead to the world that hates
and fears this fears them that gets this
x-men because right now everyone loves
heroes everyone looks i mean there's an
avengers con we need there to be a point
where it makes sense that some heroes
are hated and feared and i think the
dark avengers is going to go the adult
x-men route but i do think planning the
legal seeds with the champions and young
avengers gives us both paths to x-men
yeah you know i could see some of that
subtle
shades here what's the dodc what's his
department of damage control no no no no
no no no what's the guy's name don't
remember
he's not direct from the comics to be
honest he seems like he just has to
stick up his ass all the time man just
trying to hunt down kids
just hates kids every time he turns guys
hates kids he's like you're the worst
person ever right
that's how he talks and terry you know
it sucks you i love it having them in
there department damage control and then
also
even the way how she is with her powers
uh
because already he's like
you guys are doing some messed up things
yeah influencer wannabe chick and then
zoey who's her name zoe and then at the
end there
even with the little boy just like
theorizing here along with what you're
bringing up even with the little boy uh
who uh kamala saved clearly she slipped
up but from their perspective they're
all like why did she do that
ankle yeah his ankle is damaged now so
she like hurt this boy so it's looked
like this person's not good or this
person shouldn't be a hero or this
person shouldn't be doing this
um so yeah i think what you're at least
talking about there seems to be some
shades that seem to allude to such a
thing
john i've got a question for you yes sir
has i
pitched the ball to you i'm here and i'm
getting ready for you to i got my mitt
swing away merrell all right
we're talking about twists and twists on
twists when are we going to get a
shyamalan directed episode when all the
twists come i mean he almost played
doctor strange joaquin
i was like
who is your favorite character outside
of kamala khan oh that's a tough
question probably the dad
was great
is delightful i like uh naki a lot and i
like that they gave them a really solid
i think that was this episode i think
they gave them a really solid you know
female friendship like a real intimate
moment of friendship and of them just
conferring about like how do you do it
how do you make all this growth and this
weirdness look easy and i think their
bond together is something really nice
and special i like that it seems like
they are paying attention to that
storyline where she's running for mosque
board i like her a lot i think she's
great and i like what those characters
what she does for kamala what she brings
out of kamala and what she represents
for the show as a whole uh and just the
kind of conversations that come up
through her so i think that's probably
my second favorite character so far
bruno for you
uh you know i love bruno mainly because
he is flirty like me as we discussed
last week yeah and white and white no uh
i really like uh how do they pronounce
his name because again i always read the
dude in the car the cool guy the new guy
cameron cameron i just wanted to get it
right as i could uh come run i i don't
know if i love him because of uh what i
think they're doing or you know i mean
like there's a thing that i think
they're doing and if they do it they are
having fun watching you wriggle right
now because they know that you know but
maybe you don't i'm trying not to i'm
trying to not be the guy but like at the
same time if they do what i think
they're gonna do there's a reason the
accent switched there's a reason uh he
is a hyphen in his credit there's
there's if they do what they're doing
it's a really fun way to manipulate the
story in a way that we haven't seen in a
lot of superhero properties and he's
really like fun and charming without it
feeling lecherous which i think we might
need a koi's comic
before episode three comes out
we could do how we might get dark
avengers thunderbolts and young avengers
champions leading up to x-men and all
that things what a great efficient title
just start a board
keywords title dark avengers and
champions and young avengers and go do
you have a marvel question it's the next
week's topic on koi's comic corner guys
want
no shortage of possibilities
organizations we're getting like we're
getting like the dodc feels very
established we've got that you know the
different
parts of the world are getting more
flesh out than just shield especially
since shield's been dismantled was kind
of like rumbling back and things it's
because the first you know three phases
were kind of just hydra versus shield
and bad guys this is uh there's a lot
more layers to the world especially the
shows yeah yeah there's a lot going on
there's so many things happening because
if you think about it right now they
just had hawkeye take on the the
tracksuit mafia which felt like it was
down the street which is fun we've got
all the things happening with the tva
and loki which is another organization
we've got all the things happening in
the movies with like the magic groups
and those organizations we've also got
the ideals of the celestials thanks to
the eternals and those greater cosmic
organizations and then we've also got
like the reality of what we're dealing
with in like the street level heroes
fighting villains that we haven't even
met yet plus all the time variance
authority stuff interacting with the
small global it's gonna be crazy and i
do think we're leaning towards basically
like moon knight-esque uh blade
characters they're gonna leave the
occult thanks to the st stuff that
happens girl at witch so like lots of
tea it's like a comic book and then we
also have evangeline lily being
anti-vaxx and that's a problem for all
of us they should make a team out of all
the actors in the mcu who are anti-vaxx
and who definitely have not affected any
of their productions not a one you know
what i want you know what i also
appreciated here was the amount of kingo
call-outs oh man every time this is
filming career chuckle yeah that's right
good [ __ ] nice little bollywood because
he was like
like i like king go senior and stuff
they were saying that like they have no
idea that it's the same guy
and they were like oh how could you even
like it's like all kamel nanjani so so
genius i did like the i do like bruno a
lot i feel i i feel like he's a really
solid character felt like i wasn't
allowed to say so why you know like you
like it because
despite all the evidence of good acting
work and some some decent writing
charming and he's actually very good at
playing the guy in the chair but still
being like i like that he's a guy in the
chair and he's so supportive that is
like genuinely like never
never does the cliche of he's not the
dude from my big fat greek wedding he's
not who's like well this is all kind of
weird and wacky to me he's genuinely has
a vested interest in everything around
him and he's he's he uh he there's a lot
of admiration and respect and wants to
understand in a way that feels very
genuine and natural and i feel like
that's how you do supportive white guy
you know how and sometimes when you like
a character too much you got to worry
about him i'm not saying he's going to
die but i'm not saying you shouldn't
worry about it you think bruno is going
to die i think bruno's got some bruno is
not going to die he's going to die
i'm just saying i'm worried about him no
one's going to die in this show i'm just
saying i'm working everyone's gonna live
twice this is just saying i'm worried
about him i mean i am a little bit
worried about bruno but i don't know i i
mostly
i don't know mostly i just appreciate
too that
it doesn't i feel like the whole thing
where he clearly has
either is very protective of her or is
just straight crushing on her i like
that the way they've played that too
because while it's not like the most
revolutionary take on that i feel like
they've played it in a way that is
remarkably un
annoying and wrote
like that's something that could very
easily become like a ah come on dude
like this is kind of an annoying cliche
archetype without being played cliche
like yeah it's a thing we've seen before
but he's doing it naturalistically yeah
he makes a good ducky yeah a lot to say
about the white guy
you know what i'm just saying he's the
minority of this show you laugh because
i know that you're both getting your
heads about the white guys i'm just
aware this makes me laugh so much and
i'm like something dude just put the
pressure on us just put the pressure on
us greg here we are all right can i just
come out and say that he's my favorite
character
and i don't really care about any of
this other [ __ ] we could get out of
kamala's life and into his life
can we also like
the bracelet
i want to challenge the world for a
second though the music is such a
beautiful way to tie you into like the
feeling of being in a different world
because like a lot of the marvel shows
they use scores they use they don't
really have soundtracks that i would
like to listen to like whereas this is a
lot of stuff that feels like you can
just like actually i'd play the miss
marvel soundtrack which i don't say
about the other shows really a lot of
the times it's like what sounds like r b
music to me whatever
whatever
nowadays these days are listening to
the the rap music but it's whatever but
it's not no it's not it's the same thing
rhythm and blues either a country
classic rocker rap
the pop music landscape at this moment
in time pretty much encompasses r b and
hip-hop radio stations
country
not country r b
that's basically what pop music is right
now those three things what you're
talking about koi you don't understand
anything you only like mgk uh so he's
two genres on his own excuse me coulson
baker i'm trying to say that what they
do here is they have a lot of great
soundtracks yeah but a lot of times it's
not american soundtracks too and i think
that's it's cool to like get that
familiarity with something different for
someone who is uninitiated and a lot of
the group what i don't know the artist
or what they're playing i'm like i would
put this stuff on it's in similar ways
though i feel a lot of people maybe
discover how k-pop has become such a a
crazy part of the world now that it's
like i know so many people are into
k-pop who don't speak korean and now
listening to a lot of
the the music here i'm getting that same
effect of like damn i would just put
this on and i have no idea what they're
saying greg just said what i said while
making fun of me he literally just took
the immersive quality of my compliment
about the music but decided to make it
about him making fun of me on the
journey cory you're so self-centered
i just i i have no idea what you said
because i was thinking about what i was
going to have yeah here we are i just
appreciate that they gave the sweatshop
boys a direct call out director
good for the sweatshirt direct call out
and m.i.a i haven't heard in years used
in pop culture so i'm very excited yeah
pineapple express that was like two
years ago brandon just dropped a new
song
i like the show a lot it's in my upper
half of the marvel show so far i i put
it like obviously until it's done i
don't know how it's going to stick the
landing but i've been really impressed
number one marvel show white guild's
coming through you know i said it's
better than most of the movies it's
better than most of the comics
here we are yeah because we have the
mean koi of the most to make up for
because we're not only white but we're
dudes yeah we got all this stuff the
ethnic one you're like i'll be the dumb
one in the video you're over here being
like oh i recognize parts of mike he's
over here mia rnb and he's getting away
with it they are gonna get away with it
emma is a person m.i.a watches this
channel all right m.i.a is a big fan
yeah i love that song
take your money
float like a butterfly
yeah it's actually a biographical song
about muhammad ali oh my god
the mia covered that song the m in mia
and the a is for ali
[Music]
the lyrics are actually her saying what
she's describing all i want to do is
know his gun who's going to his cash
register she basically wants to roll up
fire a few shots and take your money
she'll rob you
it's a joyous anthem of robbing someone
else while being muhammad ali's and
bones success
three categories of music everyone which
aeronautical pop song are we drawing
from people paper planes
john denver songs here's this is you
know what's great is that we can have
this conversation there's a lot of very
culturally inspired pop music in the
show
that gives us the chance to go dive into
some of this music and find a new
fixation or find a new song that we
enjoy much like kamala's family shares
their love of their adopted bon jovi
museum prince jersey prince bonnie j i
loved hearing bon jovi referenced in the
marvel cinematic universe as beyonce was
in doctor street people are going to
click on this video man like wow their
video is an hour and a half
they must have broken this down but to
the team little did they know easter
eggs
we're talking about jefferson airplane
airplanes and paper planes for quite
some time
r b all of it guys i thought it greens
keeps you sharp
focused energetic and ready
unlock your inner superhero with a
delicious helping over 75 delicious
vitamins and minerals you don't know
this is what the surrounding area looks
like right now what matters is i'm awake
in spite of everything and that's all
thanks to athletic greens and i'm still
enjoying this show a lot dave what's her
name kamala khan actors uh yeah come on
john come on johnny
nice yeah you're gonna meet her one day
probably interview and be like hey
you're great
yeah that's the whole interview it's
going to go well i'm going to bring up
mia would you do to be great
do you like mia's r b album it should be
like who are you old man
[Laughter]
please do that
[Music]
please
i'm 45 years old
give me a break
which i've come a long way i know your
kids are
neglected we need to go check on them
that's why he's moving he's leaving him
here oh god yeah they're awful the worst
abandon your children at all costs
anyway guys are you abandoned leave your
thoughts down below
this went off the rails a long time ago
we're going to go now
in a second
john what are you doing
down here shut up oh my god
flip
you have the imagination and the
enthusiasm and if anybody is gonna
become somebody super
duper in your part of the world save the
people of romania from certain
destruction and conventions gone awry
it's gonna be you buddy you bring me
such joy and wonder but inside i know
there's a yearning to unlock something
deeper you could do it buddy you can do
it just pump it and write it and and
everything you just spin on it just spit
on it
lube it up lev
we love you and uh
and stay well out there
[Music]